j'ai envie qu'il n'arrête pas de sonner
mari hé oui la voix
oui d'alors ici la régie oui oui il
arrive tu crois vraiment connaître les
chroniqueurs oui leur amour oui leur vie
privée oui la régie tient juste at on
signalé que tout est possible c'est à
dire est que patoche du souci à se faire
la race pas s'arrête pour le moment quoi
ça veut dire que benhaim mais non mais
sur un bail on a les images non mais
c'est trop là ça va trop loin alors
qu'on a on a on a on a on un témoignage
on a un témoignage franchement c'est
incroyable des arrêts chaque jeudi les
naim
on va regarder ce qui s'est passé à
tulle de soie depuis quelques jours on
est pmp cette rumeur est en train de
faire son chemin
c'est cette tunisie naissante entre
valérie etienne et je peux vous
confirmer aujourd'hui que ce n'est pas
une simple rond et que valérie elle a
véritablement craqué sur lui alors
peut-être qu'elle arrivera pas jusqu'à
trou de batoche mais en tout cas elle
est très loin d'être insensible aux
charmes du docteur régissant les beaux
gosses intelligent il a toutes les
qualités pour lui plaire et c'est devenu
très très difficile pour elle de cacher
aux yeux de tous alors j'ai surpris vers
égard je surpris des gestes qui ne
trompent pas et je pense que c'est très
loin d'être une rumeur
alors c'est notre corbeau giuly qui nous
dira tout il apparaîtra que la soirée il
ya quelqu'un qui s'est fait parler voilà
on a on a inséré un corbeau dans
l'équipe il a alors est-ce qu'on a des
images s'il vous plaît voilà de la régie
pour illustrer tout ça si vous pouvez
lorsqu'on a des images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et plus
sourire
des champions
[Applaudissements]
les l'aiim way ma question est simple la
faim et les téléspectateurs va le savoir
et là nous regardons et en direct et
perf l année on a décidé de tout vous
dire à 21h20 on ne prend pas de
pincettes mais naim et jamie d'ailleurs
qui est ici à l'arrêt alors lui vole moi
c'est mon nom de famille alors là il ya
deux poids deux mesures non c'est dans
une famille d'amy s'appelle mohamed
jimmy tisci ça vous voyez donnait déjà
un micro à jimmy s'il vous plaît un
merci mais naim est ce que si vous
n'étiez pas être pas tort la question
est simple vous répondez oui ou non sont
sans rentrer dans les détails que vous
dites juste oui ou non est ce que vous
auriez peut avoir une aventure avec gym
oui ou non sens de rentrer dans les
détails
sans contrefaçon je suis un gars il est
trop jeune donc non non non non
jimmie rodgers si vous n'étiez pas
mariée à les premiers donc fidèle trop
vieille pour avoir une aventure avec
alors cyril sachez que ma femme est
algérienne
donc je ne peux pas répondre à cette
question donc bien évidemment que non et
d'ailleurs ma sphère ac ans avoir des
doutes
oui vraiment un m'as dit houle à
beinheim là elle exagère un peu
je sais assez d'accord avec votre sapin
c'est vrai voilà mesdames vous cherchez
dit muhammad et je cherche personne et à
force de
c'est bien en tant que champion du cache
cache à la fin août
when we search find pas mal oui j'aime
pas balancer mais à la manière des
amoureux qui écrivait sur les corses des
arbres il ya une inscription sur le
burkina mais c'est lui qui l'a écrite a
marqué quoi vb plus jm égale à e s des
amours éternelles son divorce avec un
assez joli succès jean michel cina qui
la justice et jean-michel alors tout
loisir pour pâques jimmy qui est mon ami
et je les ai vus c'est jean michel qui a
écrit ça voilà bien longtemps et alors
là c'est vous qui l'avez écrit oui c'est
mon guide et alors